et alors à anaïs est ce que vous pouvez
nous chanter quand même premiers
couplets et refrains de délibérer
délivré pour toutes les familles qui
sont devant chez eux c'est eux qui nous
regardent on voit la juste voie là où
vous vous faites que leurs frères non
moi j'aime bien coupé refrain pouvait il
faire couler bien sûr cela j'adore et
juste après on vous laissera pas ce que
je sais qu'elle a beaucoup qui veulent
regarder mac vous serez pile à l'heure
pour le match je vous lis les
avant-matches sa chère à rien vous dire
avant match après match moi je regarde
que le match voilà c'est tout alors et
vous vous allez chanter un peu vous
allez accompagner ce à quoi enfin qu'à
bien comme ça il ya intérêt je sais
combien les bébés ont je crois on a les
plus beaux éclats ça rigolait il en
régie on a les pv oil & gas et boli va
aller on va c'est parti
je n'irai plus jamais
libéré dit
suite
un royaume des solitudes qui sait
j
en levant mois
le main
j'ai lutté
ça va rester pouvoir
les tchadiens ma deux jours mans
je les sens
ciman libéré
c
je nourris
jamais
celui là
libéré
le prix de la liberté
les traçages tous les et la bombe les
ponts je signerai